with a classroom like this is perhaps no
surprise some don't want to stay in
Academia Alex is among the first group
to have done the Esports b-tech which
prepares students for the multi-million
pound industry of gaming but his
decision to now do an apprenticeship
instead of a degree was also swayed by
kovid and the fact he's never sat an
exam I personally think exams are
bad essentially I wanted to do something
with a more practical based rather than
like exams and uni work it gives me a
lot more options and you know in life it
makes me a lot more successful hopefully
Moment of Truth some like Demar though
want to go straight into work
he has the grades to do it
is that a smile how did you do I'm young
but I'm also kind of like relatively
independent so I have to kind of make my
own money and feed myself I just really
want to get out there now if you know I
mean I want to see what I've what skills
I've kind of picked up despite the
rising popularity of vocational courses
at places like this with some wanting to
go straight into the workforce this year
has also seen the second highest number
ever of University admissions with more
than 425
000 students accepted onto degree
courses
Anita is one of them going to study
games design but her excitements
tempered by concerns over the cost of
living and how she'll make ends meet as
much as I want to stand with my
decisions I I do answer like it's
actually quite worrying knowing that a
lot of things are rising in cost and is
actually going quite harder to get into
a career as because of everything that's
going on
at the University of Greenwich though
the phones haven't stopped ringing as
the clearing scramble begins more than
twenty thousand left without a place the
latest setback for the covid cohort I've
got huge sympathy I mean young people
have had a tough time haven't they but
what I'd say to them is you've had
you've come through it you know and I
think when they look back they'll
actually look back at some point in the
future and actually recognize some of
the resilience they've gained whatever
their results most will no doubt be glad
to move on and embrace whatever comes
next Ivor Bennett Sky News dagenham East
London